working out tones your muscles
i can't even say that with a straight
face the best way to burn fat is on an
empty stomach
uh yeah go ahead and crinkle that up and
throw that one away as well running will
destroy your knees
even though i hate running personally it
will not destroy your knees
my name is dr stacy morris i am the
owner of the physio fix which is in
phoenix arizona
i have been practicing physical therapy
for six years now
and my specialty is working in sports
but specifically working with strength
athletes and gymnasts
hi my name is dr wesley wong i am a
physical therapist and i have been
practicing for about five and a half
years now
i personally specialize in acls and
working with high school and college
level athletes and i work at healthy
baller
today we're debunking fitness myths
your knees should never pass your toes
when squatting
and this is something that i maybe
pushed a little bit early in my career
when i didn't understand everything
you should allow your body to move
naturally and if you limit that you
actually add more stress
as we've known through literature to
your hips and your low back
so to limit that movement is just absurd
to me and i feel like
that myth needs to die now you think
about daily things that we do
let's take away strength training beyond
that you go down the stairs your knees
go past your toes
when you play your sport do you ever
think about your knees being past your
toes and the answer is 100
no and stacy for you you were genius
like when you did your jumps and flips
and landings i can guarantee you were
never like oh no
my knees cannot go past my toes you're
absolutely correct so now we see so many
ankle limitations
because of this movement pattern that
people have been you know spreading a
myth or
trying to teach for the wrong reasons
without letting them just move like
athletes like let your body
move natural and usually it does what it
needs to do to be most efficient at
whatever movement that is
soreness is a sign of a good workout
soreness is basically when you have an
accumulation of lactate in your blood
it turns your yourself into more of an
acidic state and that's when you kind of
feel that burn
effect that people talk about is
soreness a factor of a workout
yes potentially our patients our
athletes have had plenty of great
workouts
and not felt sore the next day right
it's just the way the body is and
sometimes you just have a harder workout
the shorter workouts there's 15 20
minute workouts those are the ones that
typically i don't personally feel
too sore in but if i get like a nice
hour and 15 workout when i'm just going
hard at it that i'm gonna feel a little
bit more sore the next day but again
that doesn't mean that my 20 minute
workout was
ineffective or bad like a lot of people
they're like i can barely walk i'm so
sore
and their trainer is like good and i'm
like that's not so good like you should
be able to walk you should have been
progressed in a way that was so
gradual that you are feeling stronger
and maybe you are still getting a little
bit sore but you don't feel like you
can't
walk the next day i think rest in
recovery nutrition
sleep is super important bigger muscles
are stronger
from a physiology standpoint bigger
muscles may have the
ability to be stronger they could have
bigger
or more motor units to be able to get
stronger but that doesn't necessarily
mean that they are stronger
there are people that have genetic
differences they have longer
muscles and they're not going to be like
as like short
or as prominent so they maybe don't look
as big
but they may be really really strong
because there's more of them and there's
a shorter tendon where they're attaching
or you know there's people that have
different limb lengths your levers are
going to play into how strong you are
i do talk about size because obviously
dealing with the rehab side of things
they have
a post-op knee that looks like half the
size of the other side but i'm never
like oh you're weak because you look
like
this it's just hey let's get in the
weight room let's get a little bit
stronger let's make sure you can perform
your sport
safely confidently and all that kind of
stuff and for me that's all i really
care about is that more the performance
side of things
um and getting stronger is going to help
you in your performance level for the
most part you need to eat meat
to build muscle your eyes got big there
definitely not you do need to eat
protein to build muscle but you do not
need to get your protein from meat
sources only
they have vegan protein shakes you can
do lentils
even quinoa has protein in it cardio
before
weights what are your thoughts so it
depends on your goals
are your goals cardiovascular related or
your goals strength related i think that
that thing needs to be first
so if you're a strength athlete you
definitely need to make sure that you're
focusing on what's important
which is your strength training and this
is not a black and white thing just like
a lot of things in the fitness world and
rehab world that we work with
cardio doesn't have to be what you think
it is it doesn't have to be biking or
running or swimming like i do weight
lifting as a form of cardio because
i get my heart rate up and then i'm able
to sustain that
and that alone is cardiovascular work
working out tones your muscles
i can't even say that with a straight
face because what is toning i like like
think of toning as something a printer
does
i think when people think of tone they
think of seeing their muscles and
being like visible and it always comes
down to calories in versus calories out
and like being able to see your muscles
means that you probably are in a caloric
maintenance or deficit state so you got
to make sure you're really focusing on
what you're eating too
not just focusing on what you're doing
in the gym there are plenty of runners
out there who
dread who dread lifting um but they're
still considered
on the toner side you know and that's
where the word tone is very very
subjective
but there are other people who are on
the more strength conditioning side who
love to lift and are also
tones so again that's where the
individuality really needs to come into
play here
absolutely it's all going back to their
goals what are your goals
and for me my goals are not as much
aesthetic
anymore as they are just you know
feeling strong being strong and like
being the best version of myself
exercise cancels out unhealthy eating
habits
definitely not 100 not
my sister used to say this all the time
she'd be like you know i'm gonna work
out today so i can go to mcdonald's and
i was like
what if you're eating lots of saturated
fats and processed food it's not good
for you
and she was like but you know i'm i'm
burning more than i'm consuming isn't
that what matters at the end of the day
and i was like
yes that's important but it's really
comes down to like the things that
you're putting inside your body
that's going to have a long-term effect
it's not just calories in versus
calories out
let's hit your macros in these different
three areas like the big
protein carbs and fats whatever that is
for you
can you have your occasional cheap
burger and things like that of course
you can
if i were to go eat fast food whatever
one it is for
14 of my lunch and dinners then and i
could lift two hours a day that would
not necessarily help me
you should bulk and cut to build muscle
i have done a stint of bodybuilding
and i know that this is something that i
used to also believe before i became
more knowledgeable on the subject
usually bodybuilders they will bulk up
just to
put on some muscle and then they will
cut down so then they can see that
muscle and see what that muscle looks
like
now if your goal is not to be a
bodybuilder and you want to bulk
and cut simultaneously you can do that
but you have to be in a positive
nitrogen state
in your body and the way that you can
achieve that is by increasing your
protein
which in the form of amino acids and
also adding in creatine
and then making sure you're sleeping
enough it's not easy like putting on
you know mass and then taking off mass
because then like you're like
man i look so good when i'm cutting but
then i feel terrible when i look in the
mirror when i'm bulking and it just
throws you into this like emotional
state of like not feeling good about
yourself
i see that in some of my patients too
they don't know how to kind of return
back to normal eating because
they've been in either one or the other
for so long i think that for people who
are really trying to
you know be structured and rigid with
this there is so much help out there
that i know stacy takes on online
clients and things like that to do it in
a safe
productive structured way you need to
work out for at least an
hour for it to have an effect please go
ahead and rip that one up as well
i'm a big believer in working smarter
not harder and
shorter doesn't mean not effective the
acsm
they have those like minimum effective
dosage numbers for like adults right
over the course of the week you have to
accumulate that many minutes
of moderate intensity for it to be
considered effective for your
cardiovascular health
and then if it's vigorous activity i
think it's 75 minutes to 150 minutes so
it's even smaller
can you only survive on 20 30 30 minute
workouts yeah you can
but i think that obviously you can get
significantly more done in a little bit
more time which is
i think the hour time frame running will
destroy your knees
you can rip that one up too even though
i hate running personally it will not
destroy your knees i don't know who made
that up or when that became a thing but
it's definitely not backed by any
scientific research and i know i've read
some recent studies actually show that
runners
have thicker density of their cartilage
and their ligaments so
actually running helps their knees it
does not hurt your knees
yeah we talk about how strength training
helps to build resiliency in your
tissues and
running it actually does the same i i
was laughing when i read this just
because
i grew up playing basketball running is
involved in basketball
i work with a lot of soccer and lacrosse
players
they have to run and i can promise you
that all their knees are not destroyed
i think that the people who do have pain
with running that probably means that
their body and their tissues just
aren't used to whatever the capacity are
doing it's more of did you start you
know progressing your mileage too fast
bumping up your intensity of other
things too fast and your body wasn't
ready for it did you change your shoes
recently and now your foot has to move
in a different way
like all of those little things kind of
add up
the best way to burn fat is on an empty
stomach
uh yeah go ahead and crinkle that up and
throw that one away as well
so this is one of those ones i used to
believe too that they've come out with a
bunch of new studies to show that
no you do not have to do fasted cardio
to burn fat
obviously like if you're in a caloric
deficit you're in a caloric deficit but
then you're going to be burning fat it's
more like
what kind of workouts are you doing what
heart rate zone are you in
and then what does your nutrition look
like the intensity probably matters as
well
we train a lot of these high school and
college level athletes and they're
coming in they're sprinting they're
cutting they're lifting
we typically recommend them eating
something before they come in like even
if it's like a granola bar or something
like that
eating breakfast is fine not eating
breakfast if
you don't want to eat breakfast that's
also fine but just make sure you're
eating
what you need to be eating and getting
the nutrients you need to get throughout
your day
lifting heavy weights at a young age
will stunt your growth
i think that stacy you and i would
disagree
you and i will both agree that this is
something that maybe we grew up on
there's no evidence to support that
viewpoint that lifting weights is going
to stunt your growth
i've looked into it because i started
lifting at a younger age
i'm actually you know pretty tall for a
gymnast i think strength training does
play a a big role in youth sports and
keeping them healthy and keeping them
strong
and i also think people automatically
assume that strength training means that
you're lifting
extreme heavy weights when that's not
the case like
picking up a three to five pound weight
is considered weight training and
strength trading
assisted exercises are not as effective
my immediate thought is not as effective
as what
does assisted mean that you're just
getting some help does it mean that
you're using bands maybe a lot of people
have a hard time doing pull-ups
and they use a band but does that mean
that they're not getting stronger
that because they're using a band no it
just means that at their current
level they need a band to be able to
perform the movement
sometimes we do assisted mobility work
so you we use like a band
to assist in doing this specific
position it's actually going to help us
in the long run by using some assistance
right now
it all comes down to what's the goal of
the exercise like are we trying to
you know get more mobility or get
stronger because yeah sometimes
using assistance is what we need to use
you can't exercise with flat feet
this is just plain silly this is so
silly oh my gosh
there's like half of the people in the
world that have flat feet they're not
supposed to exercise
i'm done i'm done i quit you definitely
can
exercise with flat feet i along with
hundreds of thousands of other people
millions of other people have been able
to do it
and i think it's also kind of funny that
a lot of people still believe that you
can change
your foot shape and your your arch or
your foot if you have flat feet like
your
foot structure kind of is how it is and
yes we can get our like the arch of our
foot stronger so then you can have
better stability overall
but you can't change the structure of
your foot at the end of the day all
these myths that we talked about today
are because of extremes
don't be afraid to question things if
someone's telling that you indefinitely
have to do it
if you start believing that myth and now
telling someone else this is how myths
kind of circulate and travel and it
becomes more educated
then they can start breaking that cycle
right then and there